the part I like is that you can see into
people's homes now to like I don't know
what you have hanging on the wall there
like right behind deloria's head but
there's a whole bunch of little pictures
right now you do want to tell them where
we are
what do you mean obviously sitting on
the toilet reversed my arms are on the
toilet tank
and the toilet is up against this window
how would you know this you know this
face I'm sitting on the toilet
reverse cowboy style as they say cowboy
because the light there's a Gary told me
not to be in my bedroom because it's
this super light is too low he says that
when him oh he said that when Kim will
did your show he looked like Count
Chocula
he did yeah I'm here sit down good this
window is where the light comes in oh my
god and you out can I ask a personal
question have you moved your bowels
during this interview that would be
really that would be ours that would be
in art who have you been in when we're
done if you're recording this play it
back and I and I challenge you to find
the moment where you see me in the
middle of a sentence I'll be talking
I'll say well you know with this virus
if you seem a little
wait let me let me listen carefully
[Music]
you